you look beautiful
thank you look gorgeous um we actually
this is a strange thing
but we sang together at an event once i
don't know if you remember this it was
about
i want to say it was about four or five
years ago was it five years ago that was
a while ago
christmas in washington it's i we got to
i got to sing for the president which
was
crazy you were great i was sort of the
uh the host
i guess the guy that comes out gets it
started and yeah interstitial stuff and
then
uh it was kind of an amazing event it
was in this beautiful building in
washington
it was amazing president first lady
their children are there
not nerve wrecking at all when you're
performing it's like the ultimate
audience right and they and we you sang
you were great and then at the end of
the show
what was weird is they had us all come
out and the president's standing there
too
yeah and we sang like a christmas song
didn't we we did it was quite the lineup
it was you
me justin bieber ceelo jennifer hudson
and the band perry yeah that's fun
and the president of the president of
the united states yeah you're like
forgetting someone who is that i think
we have a picture from that event and
it's very surreal um
yeah funny look at well it was a while
ago because that was
i think justin bieber is about six years
old in that picture
it's funny when i saw that picture i
thought it was photoshopped like i
didn't think you were actually
in it but you realized that i'm kind of
you know a lot
that's a lot okay well i didn't remember
you there either that
i don't remember anything that night uh
no you know what's funny
it does look fake it looks like they
added doesn't it
i was really there it was like you're
like popped in
i was gonna photoshop myself into a
situation i could think of a lot of
other situations uh
i love your name i want to talk about
your name for a second victoria justice
and yeah it's such a cool name that i
thought that has to be a showbiz name
you came up with
everyone thinks that it's a showbiz name
my full name is actually victoria dawn
justice
and people are always like oh that must
be a stage name but it's really not
but i i get frequently people like oh
you should you could be a judge like
have your own judge show like judge
justice
oh yeah you know or a superhero i get
that often as well
victorian justice is it does sound like
a made-up name it's so cool
name's justice victoria justice
do not defy me it doesn't because i know
when i first came along in show business
people were convinced that i had
come up with the name conan i had so
many people come up to me and say man
you know because
how did you come up with that name like
the barbarian that named himself conan
but he's acting kind of nerdy but he
gives himself that name what a cool idea
i was like no that's my real name
yeah yeah that's one of the reasons for
my bad childhood
is that name but i read i think you have
a cool name
well i i i like it i like it now but i
always wanted to be like blaze whitley
blaise whitley that would be a great
name blaze whitley